there's something about the innovative
spirit
that results in a solution last minute
right before the deadline it works out
well i mean how i don't know how you did
school
probably a lot better than me but that
was how i did school i couldn't be mo i
was no motivation up until like the last
you feel like we have 22 hours to do the
entire semesters of work
like let's do this yeah and you get like
19 freaking mountain dews and then uh
yeah well that's that's why you and i
are failures in life because i just
talked to i
mentioned cal newport uh with his book
deep work and so on he is of the variety
of these creatures that
basically does everything ahead of time
that's shocking because he
this dislikes the he thinks it's
unproductive
uh to experience the stress and anxiety
of the deadline
because you're just you're not going to
be your best performance wise
and you're not going to do the best work
so it doesn't make any it's completely
irrational
to uh to a function based on the
deadline you should have a system a
process
that gets stuff a little bit of stuff
done every day so like
you should be out and constantly be
systematically honest with yourself if
you say i'm going to get this stuff done
today and this week
at the end of the day at the end of the
week you have to then reflect on what
you did who you planned
and improve that plan update it
constantly update every day every week
every quarter
whatever those durations are uh as i'm
listening to this and reading his stuff
it's like
oh yeah i agree with everything i'm like
yes i'm clapping
but like the reality is and then i go
back and just eat cheetos and like
not that it's ever going to matter
because he's so shockingly productive
and well thought out that whatever i've
decided to think about trying to monkey
wrench in there is uh
is definitely going to be able to deal
with but it's funny that again because
you're a human being
not a god all of your strengths are you
have a corresponding weakness
the less you practice working under the
gun the less comfortable you are working
under the gun the more practice you have
working under the gun the better you get
it the downside is you're always working
on in the gun so you're less productive
or it's like your work quality may be
drops
so it's an interesting thing it's like
it's almost like hey i wonder if this i
wonder if
khabib nurmagomedov has a lot of heart
and i'd say the answer is almost
certainly yes but you go
well he hasn't struggled a bunch maybe
he doesn't struggle well and it just so
happens that he can also work under the
gun really well he just doesn't like to
do it
yeah but uh yeah but it's an interesting
thing it's like i guess what is it the
aristotle we are what we repeatedly do
we are all
we are all practicing something all the
time so i guess it's it's funny i guess
that's a question that i have though
i would love to ask him it'd be really
neat is uh
in certain jobs i mean obviously you
want to have preparation
always always but certain things have
like a degree of like
entropy in the system and you go i
need to practice working under the gun
and i'm not saying that's what i need to
do because
fighting it should be for the most part
it's a really sterile environment the
grand scheme of things like fighting in
a cage is very sterile compared
to most other things in life right but
um dangerous but sterile
and uh unless of course like you know
like the other guy the
ref decides to hit you should be
hilarious but um anyway i guess just
going like okay so at what value do you
get
out of adding a degree of let's say you
could
even be planned by someone else but
junk in the system and you just have to
work under the gun to make it happen
let's say for instance for like
police or something like that the
situation turns left hard
at some random point in time that could
happen to
any number of people so i guess it's
interesting things that allow for
perfect planning or quasi-perfect
planning versus things that are
inherently unstable
and then what are the what's the
psychological fallout of comfort with
that
because i think a lot of people that are
really comfortable under the gun
let it happen a lot for all the good and
the bad of that does that make sense no
that
totally makes sense it was i mean his
answer would be
that you have to be honest with yourself
if it's valuable for the
your success to practice being under the
gun
and then you should schedule that john
then he's smart you should plan that
you should systematically and then as
opposed to doing it
half-assedly because it's as opposed to
letting the environment choose
the randomness like control the
randomness to where
like you optimize it it's so efficient
it's shocking just to hear about it
yeah no he's he's i mean the same way
you are he's annoying in the same way
which is like he he drops
truth bombs it's like yeah yeah that's
so true
yeah we're probably comparably you know
doing that you know
but he's so he his profession requires
that so he's not just like a
motivational speaker or whatever he uh
he's a a a a computer science
theoretical computer scientist and
he needs the long hours in the day of
doing
like serious math so it's mostly math
proofs and
for that you have to sit and think
really deeply it's like really hard work
compared to like uh what most people do
like
even what i i mean what i do like
programming is way easier than
rigorous math proofs because you have to
basically have this machine
and you have to uh your brain to churn
out
logic in a focused way while visualizing
a bunch of things and holding that in
your brain
and holding that for 10 minutes 20
minutes hopefully several hours
and you're not just like doing homework
you're doing totally novel stuff so like
stuff that nobody's ever done before
so you keep running up against the wall
of like [ __ ] this is a dead end
oh no wait is this a dead end and like
that whole frustration
that's serious mental work that's like
incredibly difficult mental work so he
knows what he's talking about that's
something
that's amazing but like you said he's
like this seems like the standard for
the quality of work that he needs is so
high so
almost anything less than this level of
systematization and organization would
preclude it right so he can't
afford the kind of [ __ ] that i don't
know about you but that certainly i do
which is like last
deadline kind of stuff because you can't
do that kind of work
uh last minute on kind of stuff so
my question for him in general is like
and for you and i is like
well here's these negative patterns that
we do
of like doing [ __ ] last minute and so on
is this just who we are now or are there
some
i don't think i'm really big into a free
will you know i was thinking that it's
mostly predestination
at least in this regard
you